Optimal at this altitude.
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking it.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Well,
hello there,
my dear little munchkins.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Pet some caffeine since you last heard from me.
Where you're about to hear is part two of a multipart conversation with Tony
Robbins.
To put it briefly,
Tony Robbins is a performance strategist with clients including presidents like
Bill Clinton,
Mother Teresa,
not making this up.
Andre Agassi,
Leonardo Dicaprio,
and Oprah Winfrey who calls him superhuman.
This guy is a force of nature.
If you didn't catch the first part,
you might want to do that before venturing in,
but really we jumped around a lot,
cover a lot of different topics,
so if you don't mind,
your stories is more of a jigsaw puzzle.
Then by all means,
keep on listening from this point on.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs.com the largest marketplace of
graphic designers in the world.
Here's how it works.
You go to 99 designs.com I suggest four slash Tim for reasons I'll explain and
whether you need to create a logo,
a website,
a car wrap,
a bumper sticker,
whatever it might be,
a t shirt,
you can put up what you need to description.
Then designers around the world compete for your business by submitting ideas
and designs and so on.
And in less than a week you have an original design that you love or you get all
your money back.
And I have used 99 designs for years,
including for some very big projects like the book cover or at least uh,
brainstorming book cover ideas for the four hour body,
which went on to become a number one New York Times bestseller and is in,
uh,
I dunno,
it doesn't plus languages and has sold a good Julian copies.
So I have used it when time and money has been of the essence.
It is a fantastic tool and if you go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim,
you can actually see some of the campaigns,
some of the competitions that I've run.
So actual submissions for the book covers and things like that.
You can also get a $99 upgrade for free,
which gets you more submissions.
So check it out.
99 designs.com forward slash Tim and now without further ado,
please enjoy part to the final part of the Tim Ferriss show with Tony Robbins.
And to,
to touch on a few things that you mentioned,
uh,
for those people asking themselves,
as I'm sure a lot of people would,
how,
how can I apply what these guys do to what I do?
And I think that you,
you present a of observations articulated very,
very well that most people will never be exposed to.
For instance,
uh,
number one,
asset allocation does not mean choosing if you are going to be a stock picker or
invest in an index fund for the s and p 500 because it was both your,
you're in one bucket,
right?
It's,
you're,
you're in a correlated class.
That's right.
And
right.
There's more and more companies,
but it's all within the same asset class.
Yeah.
And the other thing is that there are ways,
uh,
there are,
there are ways to look at the problem,
um,
that are not obvious right off the bat.
For instance,
uh,
you mentioned something that's so simple,
but a lot of people miss if,
if you invest and you lose 50%,
you have to now have 100% gain to get back to breakeven.
Put another way,
and this is also straight from the book.
If you,
let's just say you a,
I think it was investing over,
uh,
it was either five or 10 years,
the,
the exact number is in the book,
but,
and you had a,
you'd invested in the stock market through a,
let's just call it sort of off the shelf mutual fund that charges typical fees
and the market moves up and down,
up and down,
up and down.
At the end of that period of time,
you're back at the same market levels.
You would think if you put in a hundred grand,
you'd be,
you'd have a hundred grand at the end of that period of time.
And it ends up that you're,
what,
47% down,
four something,
a fussy eater.
It's,
it's the idea of average rates of return.
So it's a lot of people look at their,
what they've invested in their,
their broker or their,
whoever represents them.
We'll still open the portfolio.
Go Look,
you know,
you went up,
you started here,
you went up 50% you went down 50 but you went up to after you went down 50 so
your average rate of return is zero.
But when we put real dollars in there,
$100,000 and you'd go up 50 or 150 you'd go down 50 you're at 75 do you go up 50
oops and then go down and you ended up at $37,000 instead of $100,000 because
your is moving up and down.
So there are all these ways we could do the biggest one,
the biggest lie in the book.
I want you to do seven steps.
So one of those steps is,
frankly,
you got to do what most of us guys,
probably people listening on your team already do.
And that is you've got to become an investor.
You've got to be an owner,
not a consumer.
Right?
And the way to do that,
frankly,
we all know,
but very few people do.
And that's,
you take a percentage,
you lock it down,
it,
you never see it,
it's automated and you put it aside for investment.
And that just occurs.
And I showed the people some of the tools that Nobel prize winners have come up
with.
So if you say,
I have no money,
you can invest more for tomorrow by committing,
when you get a raise or your company to get to the next level,
you automatically have that percentage go there.
So it's money you've never seen.
It's not taking away money from you,
so you're willing to commit to it.
Right.
And there are ways to automate that.
Totally automate.
It was just fantastic.
So you know,
they took,
they took a group of blue collar workers who couldn't say more than 3% and they
showed in 12 years and have up to 16% would absolutely no sense of loss.
Because you know once,
if I,
they show this with example of behaviors showed me the,
if you,
if you give an a monkey in apple,
they go crazy and you give them two apples and they go crazy and if you take one
of the two apples back,
they're angry.
Hell,
they still have the same first apple.
Okay.
What happens is if you don't give them that second apple but it gets invested
for them,
you know that Pete changes your world.
You don't feel a sense of loss,
there's no trop and yet you set yourself up saving 1516 70% at a totally
different world than three or nothing.
Obviously.
Second piece thought I got through that brought this up for you is you got to
know it's great to get in the game,
but oh my God,
don't get in the game too.
You understand the rules still you're an insider and so I go through the nine
biggest lies there and their,
their investment lies there.
Wall Street wise are you want to call them,
but they're marketed wise.
There's a reason you believe very heavily marketed,
very heavily market to that.
They had to try and one of those is this idea that they're going to beat the
market.
And then here's the real facts.
96% check that 96% of all mutual funds in a 10 year period,
we'll never even match the market.
Now you're paying a premium.
You could have owned an index.
The cost you,
you have 20 basis points right at vanguard or 14 basis points manwich which
index you're dealing with.
Instead you're paying,
they say 1% uh,
you ask people,
what have I was just 1% in reality,
if you go through Forbes as shown on the average mutual fund,
when you put all fees in,
if you read the prospectus and there's all these 21 be trading,
all these things that don't,
it'll coffee's very often,
but their money out of your pocket,
the average is 3.1% now,
when you do that,
here's the problem.
Number one only 4% what's your chance of picking the 4% of mutual funds?
They're going to be succeed.
If you go for Morningstar,
you're screwed because I can show you statistically Morningstar,
its own statistics that showed a 10 year period of 250 people that made it to
five star morning star,
four or left doesn't work that way,
right?
So if you could pick the 4%,
if you were magically able to do that,
you can do oh by the 4% is always changing.
So your chances of picking the right mutual fund or 96% against you and the
average person's furrowing can't work.
They don't know how to evaluate this.
They try and tickets,
so they're screwed.
And then you get poor performance and you pay somewhere between 10 and 30 times
more for the same investment.
You kind of got for 30 times the 10 to three times less.
If I'd be ultimate insert injury and go,
why does that matter?
Well,
first,
let me give you this so people understand what 96% means.
They're getting a 4% possible success rate.
If you're going to play blackjack,
most people not apply,
right?
21 get two face cards.
That's worth 20 points.
If your inner idiot says,
hit me,
I got to face guards,
go 21 you have an 8% chance of success.
You have a greater chance success there than you did if you're going to find the
right mutual fund.
Now what's your chance of success and getting financially free when?
Here's what's unbelievable.
If if I said to you,
here's an investment,
I want you to try to,
here's how it works.
You put up all the money,
you put up all the risk and I will put up no money and I put up no risk.
And if you,
when I get up to 60% of your entire growth of what you have over the lifetime of
your investing,
you put a bowl of money dealer.
I take no risk.
I put no money on and if you lose,
you lose.
But I don't lose anything.
That's a deal that most people said I'd never taken a million years.
That's the average mutual fund because for every 1% you pay,
it's 20% over the lifetime of your investments of growth.
Because just like there's competitive brokers compound at these,
right?
So Google showed me 60% I'm saying,
Jack,
How's this possible?
How could people be doing this?
Like he goes,
Tony,
he's a $13 trillion line.
It's called one thing.
Marketing is marketing.
So I've been in the business 64 years.
It makes me crazy and people still do it.
The vast majority of people put their money in the mutual fund.
They had an index fund and now now he's come to you know,
be the largest mutual fund in the world.
But then the next time now two and a half trillion,
I mean Jack has been modified,
but most of the smart money is there.
It's not the average person's money that's in the index today.
So I go through these lies and what you don't know in the financial world will
hurt you and the one you're talking about is just the average rate of return.
You want to be seduced when you look at the rate of return.
Bubble said to me,
he's Tony.
Whenever you see what the rate of return was and you're trying to evaluate that
mutual fund based on its past performance,
just know that number is not accurate.
Dalbar did in gradable study 20 year study,
you found the average mutual fund owner over 20 year period of time made 2.5%
net.
The market was 9.7% that'll give you a sense.
So you know,
I,
I went to go do this book and I won't mention the person's name,
like all these incredible endorsements from everybody.
Nobel Prize winners,
right?
Something,
billionaires,
all these guys.
There's a particular person that I really good friend if I don't want you to
pay,
but it was ironic,
he wrote me back and said,
well,
my team's read it and they really don't think it's that,
you know,
that that special.
I thought,
well,
I'm not insulted by that,
but it's,
it doesn't make sense to me.
And then I found out this person has six mutual funds.
Yeah,
the dude gun asking Barbara my fault.
I should point out to folks also that some people are very math phobic.
Part of the reason that I went to Princeton.
And it's funny,
I was reading Carl ICAHN's story and how he was,
he was just,
you had told him,
he was told he would never get into any ivy league schools and he chose
Princeton.
Same thing happened to me.
I was told I would never get in to a whole host of schools because,
and this is kind of like your,
your mutual fund guy.
People,
humans respond to incentives and this particular guidance counselors
incentivized for what to optimize to be able to say x number x percentage of
students got into their first choice school.
So how do you do that?
Most easily lower their expectations.
Uh,
but the,
uh,
I am intrinsically not someone with a lot of math background.
Part of the reason I chose Princeton over other schools because they didn't have
a math requirement.
And I think for a lot of people listening,
they may be like,
oh my God,
percentages and compounding odds.
It's very overwhelming.
And I think that part of the reason your book had to be as long as it is,
uh,
and book should be as long as it needs to be,
is that if you were to try to compress it into 100 pages,
it would be like watching a three hour action movie.
But getting a frame every five minutes you wouldn't,
it would be too much and too little space.
But when people read the,
when I read the book,
uh,
you're leading people in a logical progression from building block the building
block to building blocks so that by the end people are very,
very savvy.
And so people who are,
who might be thinking,
oh my God,
this is,
this is really a lot for me to absorb
the book.
I'm telling you stories too.
And I think the stories take it away so it's not numbered.
You Go,
Holy Shit.
If it's to be,
if you had three of my friends,
I'll put aside the same amount of money and we both got a 7% return,
but my buddies getting fees of 3%,
my other buddies too,
and I'm one and we both put in all three of us,
put 1 million bucks in or 100,000 I do you want to do it?
I the person with 3% of these ends up with 65% less money and they got the same
rate of return.
They start with the same amount of money over the same period of time.
And I think when you see that with real people's lives,
you start to go,
I don't have to know the math.
I just know one thing,
fees matter and I'm going to cut those babies to the absolute base.
Definitely.
And A,
I'd love to talk you,
you brought it up a little earlier.
Uh,
Ray Daleo as asset allocation because it's something I've been thinking about a
lot considering that due to paper gains,
I'd say I have a very,
very,
very high double digits of my entire net worth in tech.
Uh,
and it's hard unfortunately to rebalance when you have a lot of private stock.
They can't be traded.
Uh,
but,
uh,
you know,
it,
it's the,
but uh,
Daleo someone I've been fascinated by for so long.
Uh,
maybe you could talk about the,
the all seasons and what some of the stuff that you,
that you chatted with him about as it relates to asset allocation.
It might be helpful for people to take a second and give people his background.
I mean,
Ray's not the guy you would think of as master of the universe.
It comes from Queens.
His Dad was a jazz musician.
His mom was a homemaker,
really lovely lady.
He went from,
you know,
very lower middle class family and decided that you wanted to go work at a golf
course.
He bumped into,
you know,
one of the things I talk about is proximity affects your life,
where you're in proximity with,
and he's around the proximity with very wealthy people and they're talking about
stocks and he got fascinated by it and got hooked on the process and then,
you know,
got involved in the stock business.
But he got involved in a time period when the world was incredibly volatile,
the 1970s and we're all shaped by our time periods.
Right.
And so if you can imagine,
you know,
that's a time we have this massive inflation where Nixon goes on television and
says,
we're going off the gold standard.
That money as you know what called US dollar,
we're not going to back up with anything.
And he thought for sure the markets would just be destroyed,
the American dollar is going to be worthless.
And His dad,
they had what was called the Nixon rally and it was like,
it shook him to his core that as much as you think you know,
you don't know.
And it gave him a lifelong focused.
It says,
I always want to be asking,
what do I not know and how do I find,
understand the system as a whole,
not just my perspective on the system.
And um,
and so we started Bridgewater and in fact,
my friend Paul Tudor Jones gave him some initial capital,
do this.
It is wishing he didn't loan it to him,
but would have kept it as an investment.
I think at this stage Bridgewater give so gigantic.
But what happened was he's the guy,
the u s government too,
when they're trying to figure how to design tips.
I mean this is the level design.
He's the guy that when Mcdonald's is trying to come out with egg with mcnuggets
and they're trying to figure out how can we make sure we have enough supply of
chicken and he's the one figured out the math of futures and what to do.
So Mcdonald's could even do that.
That's the way this man's brain works.
So over the years he built this Alpha Fund and it's very intensive and he's lost
money in 23 years,
three times on that fund.
And the Fund has returned.
21% owned it for 23 years.
Just mind boggling before fees and then turn around.
And after all these years he said,
you know,
everybody talks about,
different stage of life.
You want to protect yourself.
So you do a balanced portfolio,
50% 60% in stocks,
maybe 40 or 50% you know,
if you're in bonds,
because you know when the stocks are more volatile,
the bonds are going to bounce you out.
And then he says,
you know,
but it didn't look that way in 2000 didn't look there too.
That all went down 2008 right?
So over the years he said,
this is a story everybody buys,
but it's not reality,
you know,
whole segments of time.
So he began to pursue what he said.
What if I wasn't around,
I need a passive,
almost passive form investment.
I need something that wouldn't take 1500 people that my kids could use that you
know,
that would support all my philanthropic efforts if I wasn't here.
And he questioned everything about asset allocation that anybody's ever been
taught and came up with a different way of looking at it where he basically said
there are four things that move the price of any investment.
It's inflation and deflation and whether the economy is growing or shrinking.
And that creates for different seasons in which every,
every type of investment stocks,
commodity is gold,
a real estate.
It has an ideal environment which it grows and as environments in which AP will
absolutely slam.
And so he figured out what's the right combination of these things so that I can
reduce the risk to the lowest level of loss possible.
Which you know,
Warren Buffett's rules,
everybody talks about the rule,
right?
It hasn't Warren Buffet's rule,
it actually comes from his teacher,
which was,
you know,
rule number one to investing.
Don't lose money.
Rule number two,
see rule number one,
right?
So how do I make that happen,
but also maximize the mountain upsides as much upside as possible.
He called his all weather fund because it works in all weather and he did all
his own investing in for 10 years and he back tested it all the way to nine 1925
and said,
oh my God,
I have discovered something unbelievable.
So the only people got to use this is he.
And then finally his clients,
the $5 billion net worth,
the governments,
the pension funds.
So I've read about it and you know,
rate is very few interviews as I'm sure you know,
you go online,
you won't find a whole lot,
you know,
in front of the Congress.
You know,
maybe at Davos every now and then he kind of avoids any publicity and so forth.
And I did all my homework on him.
I know Paul Tutors,
one of his dearest friends,
arranged to go see him,
play it all out and I was prepared.
And then I go into this meeting and I started asking him,
I asked him a question,
I ask everybody,
which was,
if you can't,
you couldn't pass on in your money,
your children,
none.
All you could pass on was a set of principles.
And Investment Strategy in a portfolio,
what would it be for your kids?
So they don't have your skill?
Everybody give me different answers.
But his answer was,
won't be my all,
you know,
all weather approach.
I said,
so explain to me how it works.
Explain it just like me telling it to you right now real fast.
You know,
people are probably going,
I don't have a clue what he just said.
It's seems logical.
Um,
but the one thing he said is,
Toni is when people think they've got a balanced portfolio,
stocks are three times more volatile than bonds.
So when you're 50,
50 you really 90 10 yup.
You really are massively at risk.
And that's why when the markets go down and you get eaten alive.
So he has this portfolio,
describes principals.
I said,
you know what?
Right?
I said,
this is spectacular.
I understand it.
They said,
the only way you really get the result from this is if you know the exact
percentages.
It's like if you've got to,
even even if you've got some his recipe and you put in a gallon,
when they put in a teaspoon of a particular ingredient,
you're messed up.
So I say,
I need the secret sauce.
And he likes them.
He laughs.
He goes,
Tony,
yeah,
that's my business.
And that's when he gave me the whole $5 billion net worth and you know,
got out of 100 million.
I said,
yeah,
right.
But you just got to tell him you haven't take anybody's money for 10 years.
You're not going to take anybody's money.
He goes,
yeah,
but you know,
it's really complex.
And I said,
I know it is,
but give me a simple version.
And he said,
no,
you know,
it's always changing.
I said,
give me a version with no leverage and the average person can do it.
You just got done telling me and then go into their broker,
going to their wealth manager and you'll go on their mutual funds,
not going to work.
So helping the little guy out,
I know you care.
And I started teasing him.
I said,
come on,
you know,
give me the Jews.
He started laughing.
He goes,
well,
he said,
I could give you something,
wouldn't be perfect.
I said,
I don't want to perfect your worst design will be the best design anybody else
ever come up with.
Right.
So I gotta go.
He said,
well,
we might do any lays out this simple strategy.
And I was vibrating.
I mean I was like vibrating and just,
I could,
I knew what a generosity about what was.
It was unbelievable.
He's never revealed it to anyone in history.
And I ran as fast as I could.
I got in the helicopter,
flew back,
went to the guys at high tower and went to the guys at uh,
at 200 firms.
And I said,
I want you to run these numbers.
Show me the modern period.
The show me the last 30 years.
What really happened with this formula?
Every single year for 30 years.
And what's the overall for the 30 years?
Cause that's,
I look at 30 years,
1984,
that's when we finally had cellphones even.
Right.
That's when the world started.
Shift.
Show me 40 years and show me 75 years,
take me back right before the depression even.
Right.
And the guy,
the guy texted me,
I'm in a middle of the night and he never texted me and he says,
have you seen the numbers?
And so I'll never forgot.
I get up,
I call them on the phone.
I said,
what?
No,
I haven't seen him emails them to me.
And Ray was right.
85 to 86% of the time.
Every time period.
We look at between 85 and 86 30 years,
40 years,
75 years.
But that meeting,
by the way,
that's being liberal because the 15% where he lost money the most you have a
loss is 3.95% and 75 years.
And that was 2008 when the market was peak to trough was down 51% the average
loss,
including that was 1.9% so like for example,
you know,
one of his losses,
0.03 I mean really it was break even,
but we called it a lost cause.
It's technically it's a loss.
If you could go to,
and you knew that for 75 years,
the strategy you used had been successful 85% of the time and that when you lost
the most loss of 1.9% how much would you bet?
How long would then,
you know,
continue to gamble and it's not to figure it out.
So I mean,
I mismatched,
I took it,
I took it to some very large institutions.
Then they're like,
I've never seen anything like this.
So a couple of people said to me,
you know this,
let's,
let's don't put this in the book.
This is good.
This is a business man.
This is a business.
This is all,
this will give you the lowest low volatility,
the highest level of return.
It average is just under 10% return.
With that little volatility,
it's mind boggling.
So I said,
you know what,
that's not the spirit.
It was sharing it.
I said,
uh,
you know,
we can do this for people if they want to do any of that option,
but I'm putting the books,
anybody can do it.
And it's in the book right then and there.
And you know,
it's not the only one.
There's strategies for everybody,
but it's one of the more exciting ones that you'll see.
Is there anything totally up to you,
but just is there anything you can share from what to what he told you about
the,
uh,
the all weather?
Well,
the,
I will just say as a preface there,
there's so much in this book.
Number one,
I've had also people say to me,
for instance,
I'm not going to name any of my close friends,
but,
uh,
you know,
like,
yeah,
for our body,
blah,
blah.
That's fine.
Give me the index card.
And so,
and I give them the next guard and there's,
there's context missing.
And they also,
it's not just because they,
they can't in some cases do it cause they're missing the detailed,
they won't do it.
So get the book,
do yourself a favor.
I'm not holding back on that.
The reason I wouldn't share that is because it'll be out of context.
But even in the book,
I tell people the first chapter I told them this result,
even one example I said,
I know the first thing you'd want to do is turn back to that section of work.
Look and I said you could do it,
but I caution you.
There's a syntax,
there's a sequence,
the dog that judge up the dog and if you will go through the sequence.
It's going to be more of you know that portfolio,
but you don't know truthfully what your risk tolerance is.
You don't know truly what your personal goals are.
You don't know what you need to avoid on the fee structure and the tax
structures.
Then that return will be very great for you and more importantly,
you won't go through the psychology.
It'll make you actually fallen through for awhile,
but if people want to do it,
by the way,
I then went to a high tower,
which is the fifth largest restaurant investment advisory in the United States,
30 billion in assets,
13 fastest growing inc magazine company,
fastest growing company,
mazing Elliot to CEO blown away by this man.
I did an interview with them and I left there going,
this man is committed to total transparency.
This man blows out all those fees,
all this to say it in the nicest way possible,
screwing over.
That happens to most clients.
He eliminates that.
He's a former litigator.
He's got a moral code that's pretty intense.
How Optum?
As I came back,
I called him up and said,
let's meet again,
a met again,
and I said,
you know,
I want to challenge you.
I said,
how about you do this for everybody else?
If we were talking about,
I said,
how about for the average man that really needs it?
So when you're talking about,
I said,
bring that ultra wealthy advice to them.
Show them on a small scale how they they can do what you're ultra wealthy client
does.
He goes,
Tony,
you can't make money doing it.
I said,
you don't need to make money doing it and I'm doing a book.
I'm not making money doing it.
I said,
a part of our life has to be for something more,
and I said,
I know that's what you're about.
I said,
well,
I'm not talking about putting your business at risk.
I said,
let's use technology technology with lied people,
the balance.
And so we built together a site.
I put them together with this group called stronghold,
which is brilliant.
They've been managing my money from me for a plot seven years.
Aga goofy.
He's actually the person that Charles Swab put on the cover of most magazines
the last year as kind of the face of the 10,000,
you know,
restroom investment advisory,
fiduciary is around the world and around the country.
And uh,
the two of them got together,
created this site and it's kind of like check your broker.
So now you can go online and you can put in all your accounts and aggregate
them.
It's a patented technology.
You get to see a what your real costs are on everything,
all in one picture.
So there's no bs versus what you could have the same investments for.
Right.
It's like why would I pay more seconding it does,
it shows you what your real returns have been combined with first of what you
think they are.
And third,
it shows you what your volatility levels will be in the amount of risk you're
taking.
So,
you know,
and then fourthly,
it does a comparison to that versus other portfolios,
including the wind design by Great Dahlia.
And you can go,
wow,
do I want to do this?
If,
if you're a person like half the u s less than 25,000 festival assets,
you get to do the whole thing for free.
It's given to you,
you go do it.
If you are not,
you have more of a,
you can still do it for free.
He can do it yourself.
Or you can push a button and say,
I like you to become a registered investment advisor and somebody can do it.
So I got him to do it saying most of the people,
you're never going to see anything from wealthy people started not wealthy.
Right?
Right.
And so it's really cool.
It's one of those few,
according to the sounds,
when wins,
right?
These guys are adding value or got him to do it and now they're proud of it and
excited about it.
So it's a cool thing.
So one answer,
quiz URL.
The URL is a stronghold.
financial.com I've got to double check,
but I'm pretty sure that's it.
We'll double check that.
You got
to answer my question.
I don't want to cut you off.
Oh,
which one?
That
one,
and then you highlight a couple of things and you don't answer your question.
I said,
I'm not going to,
I want to cover here because even the book,
I don't feel that you get there won't mean anything to you.
I'm not holding anything back.
You going to the bookstore and opened up and read it and not painting the,
I don't give a shit,
but I think you'd be doing yourself a disservice.
Will you really want to do is take yourself to the process so that when you get
to that point you can decide,
do I want that value to be 20% of what I do?
5% 10% none 50 because there are many different strategies in the book and
including,
as you said,
David Swinson,
David Swenson is the most successful institutional investor of all time from
Yale.
He went from 1 billion,
took their monies from 1 billion to 23.9 billion,
24 billion.
Now in two decades,
he's a rock star,
a nicest human beings you'll ever meet in your life and doesn't get paid.
One 10th the rest of these guys,
it's his dedication to Yale with why he's there.
I mean,
he could leave there and be a totally different place.
We had cancer.
The man said,
listen,
I'm not going anywhere.
This is my bucket list is to be here and to continue to serve at Yale.
A man of such unbelievable integrity,
and he gave me his exact portfolio and send the book also and he actually gets a
higher return.
To give you an idea of that,
ray does,
but you have to go through a hell of a lot more volatility obviously,
so that's why your risk,
you see what you got to know what your real,
what you think your risk reward is in your mindset versus what it really is.
You'll know when you go to
the book.
If I can make a request.
Yes.
I would love for you to interview the guy who hired Swenson for Yale because
talk about the best hire of all the time.
No kidding.
I mean just the psychological profile and the guys.
So unique.
Yeah.
Uh,
the,
so a couple of things I'd love to,
to just underscore for folks.
The first is,
and again this is pulling stuff from the book.
I'm going to paraphrase some of it,
but I think it was Daleo who said something along the lines of uh,
like losers react,
winners anticipate.
But that's okay.
I'll give it to rebuild it
as a compliment.
No,
but the point being that the,
uh,
and I guess Mark Twain quote is also in there,
which was what history doesn't repeat itself,
but it rhymes.
So there are going to be crashes,
there are going to be black swan events and you want to have a plan in place for
when that happens.
And the more you can automate your many of your financial decisions,
you know,
know when to hold them.
No one to fold them and actually have a plan going in.
So if you buy something and have no plan for selling it,
you're going to be subject to sort of impulse reactions that will cause you to
do with the vast majority of people do they,
they buy high and they sell low.
So w what is in this,
what is what we're talking about when we talk about asset allocation among other
things,
just to sort of try to try to distill it for people as a concept is that you
have uncorrelated or inversely correlated buckets so that if,
if,
if one portion of your investments goes down because of inflation deflation,
fill in the blank.
There are others that go up which mitigate your risk and what you notice.
And I live in Silicon Valley,
I'm very involved with tech.
That's,
that's sort of been my sandbox for the last,
uh,
you know,
close to 10 years I guess.
And what you notice about the vet.
Okay,
95%.
So talk about venture capital is very similar to mutual funds.
So it's,
the vast majority are horrible as a,
as a class,
they're terrible.
However,
if you've,
if you pick the UNICORNS and you use the same term,
there are,
yeah,
there are a handful who are very,
very consistent.
And so what I've tried to do,
just like you did with a lot of these hedge fund managers is a look at what's
separates them and what separates them is you have the vast majority of tech
investors who think a high risk,
high return.
I've got a swing for the fences.
I'll be okay as long as a third of my startups lose money,
a third break even and a third make money does.
Yeah,
it does.
It doesn't work that way.
Whereas whereas,
whereas the guys who are really good realize that there is a power law
distribution,
one or two of their investments are going to make up for all of the losses and
the very top of the top,
even though they don't talk about it publicly,
if they have a lot of their personal money at play have thought a lot about
asset allocation.
So if they're heavily vested in tech and it might have an IPO,
blah,
they have,
uh,
they have an entire basket of shorts on the Nasdaq or whatever it might be.
So that by the way,
it's not always high risk,
high reward.
If they're tech goes to hell,
they have enough money that is betting it's going to go to hell,
that they don't lose a lot of money if at all.
Or maybe they even make money.
That's absolutely true.
And uh,
so I think the,
um,
it's a way of doing it that you mentioned,
I think you were,
may have been going this direction.
Maybe I'm wrong,
but ray down,
you actually said something in there that stuck with me brutally.
He said,
I don't care what it is that you think you're great at investing in or you like
most people invest in what they like real estate or stocks or bonds or what they
think they're good at or what they were raised with.
He said,
whatever asset class you invest in,
I promise you in your lifetime it will drop no less than 50 or more likely 70%
at some point.
And he said that is why you absolutely must diversify cause you were saying,
but I could make so much more than this side.
You know,
I've had people throughout the years,
I,
I teach this pocket theory.
This idea that if you want to do is make asset allocation simple.
That sounds like such a big word.
It's just buckets.
Some of my money is going to go into secure bucket.
That bucket is like a church steeple.
I'm going to,
it's not going away.
It's very secure type investments.
It's upside is not gigantic in terms of speed,
but you know what the compounding process,
if you give it enough time,
those low returns are giant returns still,
but you're not gonna lose.
And then there's this thing called where most people call it growth bucket.
I call risk growth because it's really risk first.
And Oh man,
I'm taking bigger risks for potentially greater rewards.
And now the question is how do I balance these?
Am I 604050508020 and that's design really by three things.
Number one,
what your real risk tolerance is.
Not what you think it is.
I do.
I do these wealth mastery programs in a few years and invariably I'll do some
crazy thing.
Like I'll say everything up,
make change.
They look at me,
go make change.
And they start reaching their pockets and making change.
That's all.
Somebody to pull out,
five bucks and 10 bucks of point $100 and they'll,
some would come up and they'll take it and give him five bucks and they're like,
you know,
they don't know how to react.
So this goes on for three or four minutes of music going on and go,
okay,
stop writes it down.
And then they go on like I'm talking about something else.
And then invariably somebody like,
Hey,
wait a second,
how I want my,
I want my hundred dollars back because what are you talking about?
He said,
I don't mind to dollars back.
The game's over.
I said,
what'd you do?
You think the game was over?
I think the game had ever gone over right,
and who said it was your $100 right?
And it's like it takes a while,
but finally,
finally get,
you know I'm stressed about $100 what do you think's going to happen when you
lose a million or half a million or a hundred thousand or 10 grand?
I mean your risk tolerance is not we think it is.
So when you find out what he was talking nonsense and we got great ways to do
that in the book and then you'd figure out really how much time do you have?
If you're younger,
you've got more time to make mistakes and so you can take bigger risks.
You know you've got a timeline on your partners and then the next piece is how
much is your cashflow?
What's that?
What's going to be the rifle?
If you look at those three things now you can assign how much goes in my secure
bucket,
how much goes my growth,
and if you don't make that decision,
it's the most important investment decision of your life according everybody.
I like what percentage secure,
what percentage growth and risk.
Then when things come up,
you're always going to go for the growth risk since look so sexy and exciting.
And I can't tell you how many people over the years have done this.
They're telling me,
why would I put money over here when I've got this real estate I'm making 120%.
I have a friend that dope,
uh,
some of the big condos in Vegas back in the boom time and he,
he actually went to my programs,
sold the business.
He had made $200 million invested in these condos,
started building the panorama towers in places that nature and he was up to like
three quarters of a billion.
I kept saying to him,
dude,
take some of your growth money and put it in the secure bucket,
right?
How many times I told you this goes tone.
I love you.
I made $200 million cause you,
but now you know,
I'm really like when I touch,
goes to gold and listened to his ego and I'm going,
I love your brother,
but I said,
you want me time to have this conversation?
And then guess what happens in 2008 how much you think you about,
he was worth three quarters of $1 billion.
He grown that rapidly.
And those short ears,
what do you think happened to his net worth?
Oh,
I'm guessing it went down according to the Ray Dalio prediction.
How about minus 400 million.
He didn't just lose what he had.
He lost everything had and beyond.
So then he's trying to negotiate and leverage,
leveraged out,
wiped themselves out.
So most people don't put enough from the security bucket is the lesson.
And a guy like Dow,
you'll provide you a strategy that's got great sustainability,
but there are many approaches in the book,
but you do have to decide how much to secure,
how much is growth.
And I show you how to do that in the book.
And I would emphasize at least,
uh,
I'd be curious to hear your thoughts,
Tony.
But for me,
it took me a long time to think,
to realize what investing represents for me,
and it's not maximizing return.
It's maximizing quality of life and there's a big difference.
Uh,
and they did it for me at least.
I've,
I've very kind of barbell strategy where I have super,
super safe,
safe stuff and then the startup stuff,
but I need to modify that.
I want to modify that because it's not currently yeah.
All seasons at all.
And,
uh,
the,
um,
so,
so for people out there,
I think who might say,
you know,
I don't want to think about it.
I would just emphasize that you're making decisions every day about where you
allocate your time,
your money,
your resources.
So whether or not you want to call yourself an investor,
you are an investor group.
And if you make no decision,
that's also a decision.
Uh,
so it's,
it's important to become literally,
I think with a lot of these basic concepts.
There's,
which is not difficult.
Do people need to remember that everybody's a financial trader,
but most people are making a bad trade because a trading time for money.
Yeah.
Worst trade of your life because you can't get more time.
We all know it.
So what this book will do,
if you're willing to just give yourself a chapter a day for a month or go crazy
on a weekend,
you'll go from maybe not even knowing what these terms sound so complex to being
juiced,
cause you'll be an insider.
You will look at the world in a totally different way.
You'll go,
that is the biggest rip off on earth that will ever happen to me.
That is where I want to go.
And you'll make some decisions and it's not an everyday thing.
Literally you might do rebalancing once a year for 15 minutes.
I mean,
unless you're going to be a trader every day,
this shouldn't dominate your life.
But you,
when did you give yourself the initial education about one of the most important
areas?
Your Life?
There's only a few areas that really impact the quality of your life,
your body,
your emotions,
your relationships,
your finances,
your career,
your business,
the spiritual side of your life and how you use your time.
About a half dozen or so,
maybe seven areas that really affect you.
But most people major in minor things,
they know so much more about shit.
That doesn't matter.
I'm saying that people give yourself the gift of just a short burst of time so
that you can truly look at life and be good at this area.
And if you want something to do at four,
you can do that.
At least then you lead them.
You're not being led by them.
Right.
No,
definitely.
And I think that,
uh,
you know,
just like one of the things that you sort of changed my world and startup
investing was,
you know,
any company you invest in should be able to return the fund just as like a
general United money that you're investing over x number of years.
And uh,
just like the sort of $1 to $5.
Yeah.
Principal with Tutor Jones and they're there a couple of pithy,
uh,
heuristics,
rules of thumb that I think will change how you view not just money or stocks,
but the world in general,
such as assume in,
in the Daleo case that you know,
your favorite area,
you're kind of investment bucket is going to decrease by at least 50% in the
next x period of time.
77 [inaudible] 78 even better
and plan accordingly.
And uh,
I think that um,
it's,
yeah,
it's been a very,
very fun process to read this and also to connect with you over it.
Uh,
let me ask if I could,
cause I know you've got,
you've got a lot planned and uh,
I also want to finish up the last few interviews in the,
in the book reading the ones that you did.
Uh,
I'm curious if there are any,
any particular funny stories or what was the funniest story or interaction you
had while researching and writing this book that comes to me?
Well,
I think the show,
one of I already,
I think it's funny now,
it wasn't so funny in the moment is walking to Carl Icahn's office,
so excited,
so prepared,
ready to rip open.
Cause this guy,
he's got the greatest returns of anybody out there.
Very few people know that Kiplinger did the first review that really showed all
the numbers.
I mean if you'd invested him in 1968 you'd have a 31% compounded return within
his firm versus at buffets him,
you'd have a 20% return.
People think of buffet is the ultimate guy.
So I got to go to these facts figures.
I'm excited to have him literally throwing my video crew out the door and then
telling me no audio and I'm like,
how the hell am I going to keep up with this guy?
Comes with the notes.
So that'd be one.
A fun moment was introducing Carl Icahn to Jack Bogle.
They didn't know each other and they're fans of each other.
So it's like I came from being an outsider to now introducing them the most of
the time that these guys wasn't as much as funny as it was fascinating.
It was just seeing the level of the,
they played the games with a great poker player.
You know,
they know the psychology,
they know the numbers,
they know the probability and you just realize why most people are never going
to win because you know,
they're not going to win gold medals against these guys that are playing this
game day and night,
night and day,
you know,
so,
and some of that is a new meat just because Paul has been my dearest friend for,
you know,
21 years now.
Um,
but it's,
it's fascinating to see that in every,
in every industry,
in every sport,
there are a few players that play at the highest level and they have one thing
in common above all else hunger.
But it's an unquenchable hunger.
You have that hunger.
I see that in you.
It's why I'm a fan of your work.
It's like you're going to keep finding the answers no matter what answer you
got.
Want to know more and every one of these people has that and it's fun to be
around them because there's energy in every one of these people.
They have different styles,
but there's an energy and that energy is driven by that desire,
that hunger to know more.
And the other observation that was reinforced by,
by reading the book was that they also,
they have principals,
they have operating systems that they use and whether you are trying to lose
weight,
trying to quit smoking,
trying to improve your investment returns,
you can insure against your lesser instincts by having a system,
putting systems in place so that when you have the impulses that are going to
lead deer destruction or eating a cupcake,
when you should need it,
that you can mitigate against that.
And it's possible you can set these things up in advance.
Uh,
I would love to,
before we wrap up,
just ask a couple of rapid fire questions.
Go for it.
Okay.
Uh,
when you think of the word successful,
who's the first person that comes to mind?
Gosh,
I like Richard Branson or know why that's first thing pops in my head when you
said that.
All the,
because I think he lives so passionately.
He lives life on his terms.
There's no bullshit with him.
I was having a good time.
It was close to his family,
lives on an island like I do.
I cause I like it,
but he's an extra,
any extraordinary leverage and very conscious man about society and what to do.
He's elders program and things like that.
He's very socially conscious and yet still has a great time.
So you'll be one of the first people.
I think it probably.
Uh,
what have you changed your mind about over the years?
Any positions you've taken that you've,
that you've reversed since?
Uh,
you don't have to be perfect in everything you do,
including not eating anything enjoyable.
Trying to be,
if they were my right foot battalion,
uh,
Gosh,
you know,
over the years there's,
you're always updating.
I mean,
I don't look at it as changing as much as updating and informing myself,
you know,
if you thought of it is changing,
I think you'd find resistance within your own consciousness,
your own identity and your identity plays such a strong wall,
but it need to be consistent with what you believe.
And that's why the political system is so messed up.
You know,
somebody could actually grow and they're seen as inconsistent.
It makes the political system not grow.
It makes us system walked in place.
Um,
so I don't look,
think there's anything that comes to mind just real directly,
but I think it's,
there's a constant upgrading and sometimes it's those two meters,
two millimeter upgrades that provide the biggest impact.
Yeah.
A side note for folks,
it's also common among the venture capitalists investors.
Marc Andreessen,
who created the graphical web browser.
Uh,
one of his mottoes for Andreessen Horowitz is strong opinions,
weakly held.
So He's,
he's,
he's ready to be corrected or update as you mentioned.
Uh,
what would people be surprised to know about you?
Oh Gosh,
that was my wife.
That question.
Um,
I don't know.
Some people would not be surprised at all people at my events.
And I'm a,
I'm a love bug.
I'm going to kind of guide that.
I can be brought to tears by seeing someone do the right thing just and yet I'm,
you know,
I'll,
I'll run through that wall,
shake the building with 10,000 people in it.
Um,
I'm a softie.
Really,
truly underneath it all.
That's what drives all this at me.
Okay.
I love to see people lit up.
I'd love to see people happy.
I love to see people freed.
So I'm going to ask a,
an unusual one given that answer,
uh,
what's the first face that comes to mind when you think punchable lunchable?
Oh Gosh.
Well,
I had a neutrally meeting with President Obama,
actually had shingles.
It was a,
I was invited by Mark Benioff to calm,
it was for,
I don't know,
15 of the,
you know,
billionaires,
they're in silicon valley.
That was s in San Jose and it was for the president and it was before the second
election,
his reelection and a,
I voted for the president,
you know,
so I'm a bit of fan of the president,
but I was getting more and more frustrated by watching the style of politics,
which was,
you know,
creating greater and greater division.
And it seemed to me a great level inaccuracy in the promises are being made that
very hard not to see.
And at that time it was the whole thing.
We're going to raise taxes on the rich and that's going to balance the budget.
And you know,
I've done the numbers,
I did a whole video on it shows you can kill every rich person,
the United States and take all their money and take all the corporations and all
the advertising from the Superbowl.
I mean,
I'd do this whole long Gig that came from some statistics,
another man put together for me,
but I did it together.
And you can't cover the budget for one year and then what do you do next year?
Right.
Um,
and so I said to mark,
I said,
listen,
I support the president.
Um,
but I said,
honestly,
I don't know.
I can support the other side,
but I don't know that I,
I'm a guy to be there.
I don't know if I'm a fan and mark and I said,
mark,
you and I are so aligned on so much,
but you know,
the way in which,
you know how Simpson Bowles was this close and he let it pass.
We have both sides willing to make some tough decisions is beyond me.
That just,
it lacks the leadership that fundamentally the president had.
States in my mind has to have it.
That's my judgment.
I'm just a person.
But it's like I don't understand it was taking the easy route is not something
that's going to sustain or grow this economy longterm.
And,
and I said,
Ann,
and using the political capital,
even though I'm supportive healthcare using that healthcare,
we're half the country is upset about it and pushing it down their throat and
trying to say it's going to cost less money.
I mean,
it's just like there's certain things,
so much as I agree with you,
I agree with you.
And Mark is the second largest fundraiser for the president.
So I said,
well then how the hell he raised all the money.
He goes,
well cause I feel strong about him and the other guy.
And he said,
and you and I are aligned with them on so many other things about you know,
the environment and you know,
you know people's right to marriage regardless,
their sexual preference.
And I said,
of course we are.
So he said,
come,
come and be there.
I said,
you know me,
I'm totally respectful,
but I'm honest.
He goes,
come.
He says,
I'll sit,
you're right next to the president.
He said,
well,
have a great conversation.
So I went to this,
to this meeting and it was crazy.
I mean I've worked in so many presidents over the years,
but I'm not going to bottle.
And it's downtown San Jose.
If they locked everybody in their buildings and literally,
you know,
it looked like one of those movies,
when everybody's died and there's nothing left.
But the buildings,
it was,
it was the wildest thing for several blocks.
It took us up in this room,
there was nobody else,
seniors,
these 16 people,
many of which you know from Silicon Valley.
And,
and I listened and present,
came in and it was really wonderful.
And he shared,
you know,
some comments and said,
I'm not here to give a speech.
I'm here.
You guys had built the biggest companies in the world.
I'm thinking,
not me,
I don't fit that category.
And so I was going to say anything and he said,
but I really want to hear from you guys.
So mark turns to him and says,
well,
are you ready for some real give and take spreads me?
He said,
yeah.
He goes,
okay,
who wants to go first?
And he pointed straight at me.
That's a friends and boy,
I said,
Mr President,
I've paused.
I literally pause it.
I shouldn't do this.
I'm not here.
And they won't pay a quarter million bucks to be here.
I actually have never done it where I went.
Thousand 1000 xe.
If somebody else is going to say something we have,
I said,
okay.
So when Mr President,
I said,
I really want,
you know,
I voted for you.
I know you've had a tremendous integrity.
I share the same values you do,
I believe.
But I said,
I'm really confused about two things.
Number one,
how you think you'll be able to have a,
you know,
a second four year run and get anything done when you have taken the other side
and demonized unto a point that they're never going to work with you.
And my second question,
if I ever get one would be,
why didn't you support Simpson Bowles?
Right?
I said,
it was right there.
It needed to be done.
And He,
you know,
he's long pause.
And he said,
well,
those are fair questions.
And he said,
uh,
he is the,
first of all,
I don't think I've ever demonized the other party ever.
And I just sat there and watched him saying,
I was like,
are you kidding me?
I mean,
I'm not a Republican,
but come on.
Right.
You know,
both sides of demonize you and Kim.
And he goes,
and they've been really unfair to me.
And he went through this piece and I said,
Mr President,
that's happened with every president.
Fair.
You know,
that's,
that's what they both do.
And it's gotten worse throughout the years for sure.
I said,
but what about Simpson Bowles?
And he said,
well,
Tony and eat,
you know,
every has a research about who's in the room,
the president.
He goes,
well Tony,
you know,
your friends,
your hedge fund friends,
he said,
you know,
they wouldn't like it if we got rid of,
the 15% tax so they can do and they win.
And he goes in,
you know,
most Americans would like it if they got rid of their mortgage deduction and you
know,
one else thinks.
And he said,
I got a better plan.
And I said,
the better plan is you're going to raise taxes back to Bush on the wealthy.
it takes $4 billion a day to run this country.
And you know,
as well as I do,
the estimates of all that money in won't even cover three months of this
government spending.
So it won't solve any,
you're gonna have to raise taxes on everyone to cover this.
I said,
so how do you deal with that?
And he and I went back and forth and to be fair,
I'm telling my version of the story.
I'm sure he'd give you the version story,
but there's a point where I was,
I felt I'm losing rapport with every person in this room,
but I had to be honest.
And,
and finally at 1.6 years and came over and grabbed my wrist and he said,
I think that's enough.
And the presidents,
uh,
I wasn't even raised my voice.
The presidents,
uh,
you know,
to honor him,
he said,
no,
Tony,
he's created some creative tension here.
And he said,
I'm not used to that and these rooms.
But he said,
it's fair question.
I said,
you know what,
Christina,
I just want to know because I voted for you.
And a lot of people I know that voted for you.
And I don't know if they will.
Again,
I don't know if they need to.
You're going to win anyway.
Yep.
But I'd really love to know what to tell them about how you're going to govern
with this level of division.
And so at the end I just said,
well thank you for your time.
And then everybody else got up and ask the questions like when you give a shout
to the Jews,
and they were like that.
It doesn't have no hard balls in there at all,
but you know,
as a political environment.
So afterwards I thought,
oh my God,
he's gonna to hate me.
And the Reed Hoffman walks up to me,
you know,
from linkedin says,
I can't believe you asked him that question.
I can't believe you asked him that.
He said,
I've been wanting to ask him that question forever.
I would get on even a health.
People come up to me,
give me a boot.
And then the present gave around and we came back around to,
it's shaking,
his hand shakes my hand.
I shook his hand and I grabbed him with both hands and I pulled him close to me
and said,
Mr President,
I said,
I'm not some stupid Republican who's just looking for some tax break.
you know,
this week I thought a quarter million people in San Jose,
I don't live here.
I came in to do an event.
This is what I do.
Wherever I go.
I came from nothing and I don't forget where I've come from.
I care as much as you care.
But I said,
I'm really concerned about your ability to get your agenda done in the next
season of your career.
If you don't find a way to bridge your communication style with these people,
intelligence is not enough.
You've got to build relationship.
And he stared at me and he said,
how about you weren't like Keith Cheeky Chief of staff and you come visit me,
the White House you and I want on one for an hour.
I was like,
blown away.
I thought,
you know,
I didn't reach him at all.
It was mind boggling.
So,
uh,
mark was right there.
He goes,
that was unbelievable.
That was the going of,
I love that,
you know,
Mark Club,
I love seeing that that edge back and forth he use can really help.
So then,
um,
about a week later they were getting ready to these debates and the other side
called me and asked me if I would work with their particular candidate privately
and I'm not one side of the,
I wouldn't want to see a debate that's real.
So I worked with Mr Romney and that's the first debate they went in and he did
pretty well and my invitation was no longer extended,
so I wouldn't say punched in the mouth,
but I'd say frustrated because here's a man who has such integrity,
president had states and I think a classic human being who cares deeply smart as
a whip,
but it's,
you know,
the failure to find a way to bridge compromise is both sides responsibility.
But in my mind as a citizen and then the person had,
states has got to make that happen and their presence have done that.
And presidents that have it.
And I think that's not his fault,
but we're at an impasse politically.
That is not allowing us to do the things that I think are necessary for our,
you know,
put our house in order in this country and easy for an outsider see it.
But as a citizen,
we all have a right to opinion.
So I don't know,
think punch,
but I'd say you have a shakeup.
Metaphor might be a better one.
Wow.
That's a hell of a story.
I,
uh,
one last question and uh,
I think people are really gonna enjoy this and I can't wait to see the comments
on the questions also.
Uh,
I have my moments of doubt,
dark moments.
I don't know if you have those,
those,
those moments of doubt yourself,
never.
What do you do?
Uh,
when you have those,
those,
those dips,
when you have those,
those down moments and,
uh,
those moments,
those moments I've experienced primarily when I found an inner conflict,
uh,
that it's hard to resolve.
Um,
and that was been in the past when I'm traveling around the world,
you know,
I feel like I made to do what I do is human being.
I'm certainly not the only him being can help people,
but I'm able to have a lot of people and I've filled,
it's a privilege and it's um,
it's a gift and it's something that's earned and something that is part of
grace.
And um,
and yet I,
the greatest thing in my life outside of my work and my family is my wife.
And ironically I met her,
she had extreme motion sickness since birth and I spent almost a decade going
everywhere cause she would throw up on,
we never want to be apart.
And she would throw up on the flight up and on the flight down.
And she literally lost,
I don't as 19 pounds,
which she couldn't lose.
She was a size zero.
I took her to every type of physician.
I took her to every kind of natural healer,
an acupuncturist.
I took her to NASA thick expert there.
Nobody's able to help her.
I took her to the guy who works at the top gun pilots because if they lose their
budgets,
stipular system,
you know,
you know they're dead.
So you had the system and he was the only one who can help her,
like maybe 10% of the time,
not throw out the process.
She did cause this antibody created a constriction of lymph fluid and she
developed a tumor.
And so the darkest days are,
you know what I think I made here to do and it is hurting the person I love most
or I've got to be a part and you know,
Corny as it sounds.
I just,
I just believed that there was a larger lesson that I need to find a way to
break through.
And we finally did and she know like she doesn't love motion but in Oregon
throws up on any flight and it was ironically and experience in India,
which sounds so bogus to me,
but I experienced it and she's never thrown up since that time is mind boggling.
It's just man who's,
it doesn't,
he's not of any particular faith that's called oneness.
And uh,
he does this form of meditation work where it basically prime your brain to a
certain way of being and it balanced her body out.
Just amazing.
Um,
but the point of the matter is,
I went through all this pain,
all this question,
all this doubt,
but I kept asking what's right,
what's real.
And I trusted my gut even when it was painful to trust my gut.
And I found that that's probably the most useful thing.
And the other thing you got to do is ha sounds stupid.
Hydrate your ass off.
Make sure you rest,
because in a lowered state of energy,
you'll doubt everything.
And in the worst thing can happen if you are what I call energy rich.
If you are it at a peak,
you can slam anything against you and you'll know.
Um,
and so that's not to say you won't have those downs,
but that's what I tried to do.
Put my body back in the strongest place that will put your mind back there.
Your heart is always there and then ask what's right and live it and you're
gonna still make mistakes.
And when you do,
I think it's being forgiving herself and learning from it and moving hell on to
what's next,
as quickly as you can so that that experience allows you to help other people.
And for me,
the worst events I've ever gone through my life,
I've always been the best events cause I figured if I'm experiencing this
someone else's too,
and if I figured out I can help millions of people and that's given me sanity,
so I'm not just dealing with my pain or bullshit or whatever the case may be.
And that's,
that's a big part of my life is ending suffering,
which is impossible,
but ending it in areas of people's lives is possible.
And you know,
it was like always say it was corny.
You know,
suffering is optional.
Paying Kane,
you know that everyone's got pain in the left,
but suffering is optional.
And I really believe I can help people get out of that.
More importantly than get out of the suffering is to give them an experience and
more than joy that's already inside them.
And I lived to see that light in their eyes.
And I'm going to look forward to seeing you at some point out of that cause
you'll have an experience of it and it won't be this discussion because
discussions,
wonderful experience 10 times better.
I always tell people,
you know,
a belief is a poor substitute for an experience,
right?
You can believe all you want about what you think something is or investing is
or what China's like we'd go to China getting the experience,
go to event,
venule know.
And I'm a big guy on put people in the experience as quick as they can and let
their spirit and their heart and their soul kind of take over.
And that's what my life's about.
To get admission.
It's an amazing mission.
Where can people learn more about the book?
Come on that you,
where would you like him to go?
His,
I'll give you the address,
but they can go to Tony robbins.com.
That's the easiest way.
And the book again is called money master the game.
Seven simple steps to financial freedom.
And,
uh,
what I'll do is I'll give you a site and if people decide to do this and they go
to Amazon,
it,
they'll send me the receipt.
I will give them something I did for people during the pre publication period,
which is I've made three videos that are kind of a fast track.
So somebody going to like 600 pages seems like a lot to me.
Well here's this,
we'll get you going.
Um,
I think for a lot of people the audio video approach is a good approach to them
and then it'll take them deeper in the book.
But I do want you to know that most people,
I don't know if you're experiencing this and this,
we read the book or entertained because it isn't just like some heavy factual
piece.
It's take,
it takes you on a journey and it's a journey through financial world,
which was wild,
weird,
crazy stuff happening.
It's a journey to the lives of people that started with nothing,
that are the wealthiest people in the world.
How they did it.
And your own journey about where you're going to take yourself from this point
on and how you want to live that life and experiences that you want to not only
have for yourself,
but what you really want to give.
And,
and that's the greatest thing.
I,
I look back and you think about money.
Money is nothing but a tool that you either use for a life of service in a life
increased the quality of life for yourself and the people you love or it's used
on you cause a weapon.
And I'm big on saying time for it to no longer be a weapon used against you.
And the only way to do that as educate
yourself.
And you can do it in a way that's really fun.
And that's what this says.
Oh,
absolutely.
So guys,
check out the book.
Check out Tony.
Uh,
Tony had a huge impact on my life and just to the entertainment aspect of the
book.
Uh,
I have tons of books sent to me.
I mean dozens a week cause I'm sure you do.
Huge stack.
A lot of the questions that I asked did not require me to read the book.
And I ended up pushing off probably a half dozen important projects of mine
because I got pulled into the book and I remember I emailed you and I said,
you know,
it's been 20 years,
you still have it hot.
Damn.
Like I that feeling that sort of the Tony Robbins response that I had reading
your material back in high school and remember you emailed me or like high
school.
How old are you?
It's,
it's a really fascinating read and I know some of you listening are,
my friends are deep in the world of finance.
You will find things,
uh,
in whether it's in the interviews at the back,
the profile,
some of the,
uh,
you know,
the top performers over the last several decades or within,
it's a really fascinating romp with lots of good stories.
So Tony,
thank you so much for taking the time.
Definitely hope it's not the last time.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Thank you for supporting the sponsors of this show.
I've used them,
I liked them and I think you will too.
99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
it's the world's largest marketplace of graphic designers.
You can see the projects that I've put up,
the competitions that I've spearheaded,
including the book cover of the four hour body,
and you can also get a $99 upgrade for free,
so check it out@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim of course you can
subscribe to this show on iTunes.
You can also find every other episode in the show notes,
links from this episode@forourblog.com that's f o u r h o U R B l o g.com and as
click on podcast,
there's all sorts of other cool stuff including my interactions with people like
Warren Buffet,
Mike Shinoda from Linkin Park.
The list goes on and on and on and I would love your feedback.
Let me know what you thought of this show.
Who would like to hear on the show next and any other thoughts really?
You can find me at Twitter at [inaudible] Ferris,
that's twitter.com forward slash f e R,
r,
I s s and on facebook@facebook.com forward slash Tim Ferriss with two r's and
two s's.
Until next time.
Thank you for listening.